[Music]  these games belong to Ryan Lochte one of  the greatest swimmers in this room  breaking news to report at the alleged  armed robbery all morning there were  conflicting story there was no robbery  there was no pull over without his gun  [ __ ] pit put into my forehead  now we had to give a money something  could have ended my life because I was  stupid I went from making millions to  zero the person that I am today if I saw  that Ryan Lochte I would knock his ass  out there's so much more to life wake up  this is the most pressure I've ever had  in my entire life if I don't make the  Olympic team they won't see the change  that I've made it's all or nothing no  [Music]  you